What are you doing?
Taking off my shoes. What do you think I'm doing?
Did you ever hear of anyone taking a shower with their shoes on?
I usually sing a medley of old favorites when I'm in the shower.
Oh! Any requests?
Shut the door!
Oh, I'm afraid I don't know that one miss. Well.
Why? Come in and watch.
Drip-dry!
How often do you go through this little ritual?
Oh! Every day. The manufacturer recommends it.
I don't believe it.
Oh, yes it... Wait a minute.
Read the label. Look, look at the small print.
"Wearing this suit during washing helps protect its shape."
Waterproof.
Acronylon. Fibrous resistant. Plastic. Rustproof. Fly-proof. Proo-proof!
You're the nut.